the Joe Rogan experience these last 10
years but how different has it been you
know what I'm saying yeah his last 10
months last 10 weeks things have been
crazy so weird time to be alive things
are happening very rapidly from the
invention of the cell phone to social
media to the ability to share videos and
for people to get information for people
to find out about world events for
people to get together and and and and
try to make change it's just a different
world man it's a different world in good
ways and in bad ways it's a different
world people are more disconnected than
ever while being more connected than
ever yeah there's a lot of things a lot
of things about this life that are
really weird do you think I was getting
better I have hope man when I see like
yesterday there was part of the George
Floyd protest in downtown LA had filled
this it's a craziest picture man you see
the picture of the street filled with
people all nonviolent so all the the
looting and all that [ __ ] seems to have
stopped and now the people that remain
seems to be they seem to be dedicated to
change in a way that I can't remember
anything like this in my life I think
this is this has a real disc of this
man's murder has a real chance of change
in the world and changing America for
sure I think it really does it has a
chance and in further bridging the
divide between people and to to get
people to look at things in a in a
better way like look how many people got
together for this look how many people I
mean it's it's you know it had the real
bad parts in the beginning with the
looting but I don't think there Cannell
t this is the same people I think those
are people that are broke
cuz kovat kept them locked up in the
[ __ ] house for a month at a time
without any ability to make any money
and I think people saw free [ __ ] and
then everything got wild and it was
jumping off and people were smashing
windows and a lot of people just stole
[ __ ] that's what I think but I don't
think that's the same thing that's
happening I think that's happening along
with this protest and but the protesters
protest is pretty [ __ ] amazing when
you think that this in our time we've
never had a moment like this work
literally the whole country is getting
together and saying things have to
change and stop their defunding the
Minneapolis Police Department man what
about Rasoul oh yeah so I was too young
again so I would ask you for this the
Rodney King [ __ ] that Ronnie King wasn't
here for that I watched it on TV but I
was in New York I came here right after
the Rodney King [ __ ] but the thing about
the Rodney King [ __ ] was it was confined
to LA you know people weren't right
writing about Ronnie King in New York it
was just an LA thing these riots were
all over the country man I mean the
Freddie what happened is was that guy's
name in Baltimore Freddie gray yeah that
was the last big when I remember that
was about five years ago and when
Freddie gray was killed by the cops they
went crazy in Baltimore and lit
everything on fire and smashed
everything but he was still just
Baltimore you know with George Floyd
it's the whole country now it's just an
excuse it was it's this is what it is
man it's like people are fed up people
are pissed yeah but it's also they're
also broke man they got and not it's not
through any fault of their own they got
stuck in this kovat thing like we all
did and they were forced to not be able
to work for months and months at a time
and most of them still aren't back at
work right so they're broke and they're
[ __ ] and then this is a chance to
steal some [ __ ] I don't condone it I
don't condone it
but I saw a lot of look what looked like
high school kids running out of those
things holding boxes of sneakers like
they just were taking advantage of free
[ __ ] and yeah there are some bad people
in there too there's some criminals in
there too there's some people that lit
you know churches on fire
there's some people that did some
horrible [ __ ] but I think the whole
movement is not connected to that that's
just some people that did some [ __ ]
taking advantage of a moment in time
where everything went haywire but the
people that are marching they're doing
it very peacefully in these enormous
groups I think it's got a real chance of
being something that that changes the
way cops interact with people it's got a
real chance
it's so big yeah I guess that's a
fighter like you don't you don't like
you like rough play with your friends
and you're a little kid and then all of
a sudden there's like a mosh pit
anything she know you're freaking here
you know you're you're being suffocated
but all but about everybody's way like
that feeling like these cops they think
you know sometimes the people that are
being arrested they're their fighting
men because that's a lot of pressure on
the neck or that's a lot of pressure on
the stomach and things like that you
know so they didn't make the excuse that
you're resisting arrest but look
everyone's gonna resist when you put
your [ __ ] chin on their neck yeah you
know that's crazy that's torture and
also the way the guy was lying down when
he had his chin on his neck he was lying
with his neck against like this drain so
this is like this like cement drain area
and his neck is right there so his shin
is on the top of his neck and then the
drain area is the bottom it's [ __ ]
horrible it's horrible to watch man it's
so keep watching God getting tortured to
death like something has to be done now
I don't I don't think it's defunding the
police I think it's definitely get rid
of anybody like that guy and it's
retraining them train them with where
they realized that like there's a chance
to there's a chance to do this correctly
you you give it an amazing job being a
police officer is is incredible
responsibility and it takes an
incredibly powerful person to do it and
not abuse the power that you have
because people have a tendency when
someone says why do I have to do that
because I [ __ ] told you I'm the cops
like that's what they're doing when they
have that kind of power they just go to
it right away it's you you get you need
exceptional people and there's a lot of
people that aren't exceptional and some
of those become cops and you see these
non exceptional people who are cops who
abuse the [ __ ] out of the power that
they're they've been given that's the
problem I don't think the problem is
that we don't need cops like Jesus
Christ if someone's breaking in your
house you want to be able to call the
cops
if you got a real problem in your life
and you know there's something going
wrong you want to be able to call the
cops but they have the cops have to have
a better relationship with the people in
their communities
[Applause]